welcome to this video playing Yardbird
here with white and what the heck did he
chew it is rating this is not fair
playing against such a strong player
with this no rating in comparison to
what is capable of doing okay got
probably in a wood Indian I normally
play with you for Bishop g5 is also a
good line this is how I normally play
that with a four before there's a five
so let's stake here is it rook takes I'm
not totally sure or queen takes hmm OOP
takes I believe an interesting way to
play at the end you will have 94 if I
take on a six so maybe that's not such a
brilliant idea to take a six rook takes
rook takes Bishop takes Knight to g4 and
he will get my dark squared bishop okay
maybe try to keep the pressure on okay
Quinn to be eight hmm chance maybe gave
up getting in Bishop b5 him but okay
it's not fatal or anything um SF 3 a
move maybe
yeah I want to cover your fault so that
I have night c4 hmm that's a
surprisingly difficult this position
okay night c4 we should be higher so he
really has chances to get this traded
mmm queen bee three maybe to prevent the
immediate trade I have it takes that
would be aid you can go back to back to
d2l maybe not interesting played this
very interesting way as usual maybe rook
f4 is not really good yeah because of
Bishop g7 maybe but the core not i'm not
sure about this position it's not like
i'm in a in a terrible situation here
but normally this opening really should
yield some advantage for white nothing
brilliant but something to work with i'm
not sure i have something here
Tim I think he probably needs to trade
queen cm
taking on a six was probably not very
promising because of this should be six
or sometimes he just gets me too so
interesting now what does this move we
should be five I probably just take yeah
I thought maybe two maybe capture on b3
play would be eight but I probably just
go back to the two and it's not clear
that this is this is any good for black
interesting to a five so i can trade now
if I like and play night to see form
okay
this should be five might be a smooth
ride I can I can play king f2 then cover
you have the e2 and still and still a
check t6 so this may be forced to trade
now and this should be quite good be 3m
and I'm going to win the a porn at least
in the near future maybe 97 now mmm
maybe you can play 97 up to take on b6
with a night maybe
I take it he gets to the second rank but
I also will get play against the d6 pawn
or became one I'm not sure damn come on
and so I get this and get this going
okay I didn't really expect that that
exact move order can play would be
whenever I want and keep the pawn for
the moment rugby aid i have also be
formed he cannot take because of the
week back ring so now rook b5 is this is
a rope trade I thought rook c5 but he
has he has luque to perform or yeah
before I guess then so not exactly clear
what is what is doing now night a4 may
be right if I have look f5 or rook be
seven or maybe this one i deciphered
rupee 70 isn't this a double attack on
the rook and the night I don't see a
reply here black resign okay so one in
the back in this in this big match and
I've gotten to almost fifty percent now
but just minus one
yeah I am not really sure about all this
let's let's start here around here we
have a theoretical position the question
is however how should i take i took with
the rook hmm it looks really normal i
take with the Queen he has this energy
form immediately and i'm not sure i have
anything here if we consider something
like that I mean he probably will get
this Bishop to b5 and this protects all
of his weaknesses so maybe this is right
now this and yeah I really don't want to
take if we look at this we see that like
a really got some activity here you will
probably take Bishop here or sometimes
queen over here I don't like that so I
guess this is right and now this move I
went to f3 to make sure my center is
secured and I can actually move this
night somewhere mostly to see for he
went to Bishop d aid and now I went
queen bee three young Wow was the top
engine move for him this was good yeah
I'm I wasn't really sure about all that
but as it seems that queen bee three is
right because it's the only morally to
prevent the quicker be should be six
from happening TI played a five it's
also the best defense according to the
comp but it should give me an advantage
by trading and 94 just how I played
Bishop c5 and now the comp wants to play
book see one okay I went here the second
best move but it keeps an advantage so
I'm really satisfied yet seems that I
handled this well I wasn't really sure
about it in the game but it seems that
it's okay 97 now seems to be better and
white has an advantage but nothing
decisive
after this it probably is very tricky
now the a bonus is very tough to to hold
I was actually expecting that he will
play Knight takes b62 want to play to
somehow play this position check but
maybe this is also not helping him very
much now something like this I have a
counter check on the pawn on d6 ok so
you went here an errant here yeah and
probably rook be a dispatcher I mean
before us maybe even stronger ok what I
wanted to play it simple and here before
is flat-out winning this is really
winning and this is what I expected and
I wanted to go Rugare 5 which is
approved by the comp that's good
something like that seems to be best and
then I wanted to play with a one
actually now ok why this is basically
winning with the beep on it would have
been metal of good technical play with
white is winning ok thanks for watching